un comité d'accueil donc d'alexandre
loukachenko se serait bien passée ce
lundi tandis que le président biélorusse
rencontrait les travailleurs d'une usine
de véhicules lourds en grève des
protestataires se sont massés devant le
siège avec ce message à l'adresse du
leader politique va t'en plusieurs
autres usines ont également répondu à
l'appel à la grève générale lancé par
l'opposition pour protester contre la
réélection controversée du président
biélorusse nous sortiront chaque jour
dans la rue pour manifester
il faut faire bouger la classe ouvrière
si cela n'aide pas il faudrait que le
soir tout le monde sorte une colère qui
s'est propagée jusqu'au siège de la
télévision publique biélorusse à minsk
pas de quoi déstabiliser alexandre
loukachenko qui a minimisé la portée du
mouvement de contestation
on vous pousse dans le domaine politique
ou certains d'entre vous sont passés
dans le domaine politique mais retenait
cela d'autres lots à règne dans le
domaine politique là où vous vous êtes
précipité sur le comprendre
d'autres lois pour que ça ne se passe
pas mal ni à moi ni à vous ni au peuple
quand nous perdrons notre état deuxième
chose si quelqu'un ne veut pas
travailler préfère partir on ne va s'en
prendre à personne on ne va faire
pression sur personne
je vous en prie dès demain ou même
aujourd'hui les portes sont ouvertes
pardonnez moi cette phrase impopulaire
mais le moment exige de parler
franchement
l'union européenne n'a pas tardé à
réagir
l'allemagne qui assure la présidence de
l'ue a menacé d'étendre les sanctions de
l'europe contre la biélorussie une
réunion de crise doit désormais se tenir
mercredi entre les vingt-sept pour
évoquer le dossier biélorusse
je vais convoquer une réunion des
membres du conseil européen ce mercredi
à 12h pour discuter de la situation en
biélorussie le peuple biélorusse a le
droit de décider de son avenir et
d'élire librement son dirigeant la
violence contre les manifestants est
inacceptable et ne peut être autorisée
emmanuel macron à lui affirmé le soutien
de l'europe aux manifestants biélorusse
réaction cinglante de maria zakharova la
porte parole russe des affaires
étrangères
le président français emmanuel macron
crois que l'union européenne doit
continuer de soutenir activement les
participants aux manifestations
pacifiques en biélorussie il a publié
une déclaration en ce sens qu en
demandera thil a lieu de continuer de se
mobiliser aux côtés des centaines de
milliers de gilet jaune qui cherche à
faire respecter leurs droits leur
liberté et leur souveraineté lors de
manifestations pacifiques
quand lieu cessera-t-elle d'attendre les
demandes des présidents de ces états
membres et commencera-t-elle à se
mobiliser de façon proactive pour
soutenir les manifestations sur son
propre territoire un bel exemple
d'hypocrisie ce lundi alexandre
loukachenko a admis la tenue d'une autre
élection présidentielle à condition
qu'une nouvelle constitution soit adopté
l'avenir du président biélorusse à la
tête du pays s'annonce de plus en plus
incertain son opposante êtes la nati
canucks callas en exil en lituanie s'est
déjà dit prêt à devenir le leader
national du pays